are you ready to have more children I
mean yeah I mean again I think a lot of
has to do with a being with the right
person but also with I think we did a
humdinger of a job on the one we got so
that was Jason Sudeikis promoting his
new movie mother's day just days before
fiance Olivia Wilde announced she is
pregnant with their second child what we
love is how much he loves his son Otis
who's almost two years old he loves
beyoncé right oh yeah yeah yeah which
makes him human but yes yeah he doesn't
ya know he does literally enjoy watching
her perform when she [ __ ] songs lives
water broke at a John batiste you know
the music director from from the Stephen
Colbert he wasn't that yet his band stay
human but the water broke at a concert
oh really yeah so he's probably dancing
in there and then how yo boobs or water
yep just brilliant thank you listen the
break dance break dance and put the one
who wrote the water what does it look
like to break your water at a concert oh
well it was a hind water leak so it
wasn't too bad she just thought she peed
her pants